so
your boy trumpito is gone they get him
out of here they're burying him
under the jail how do you feel about it
is he gone gone
and what's the point of impeaching at
this at this stage
there's a few super smart super smart
okay so
the way that i've been kind of looking
at this thing is obviously democrats
hate trump right not only because
there's popularity but because of a lot
of his
principles go against theirs right so
they're going to fight against this guy
who's not even playing by the political
rules yeah if you say
right so they're out there trying to be
all politically correct and everything
and i'm not talking about like using pc
language like genders they're like
literally trying to like operate in the
way that they are used to and accustomed
to operating in politics
and trump out there like [ __ ] this [ __ ]
yeah he's just saying wild [ __ ]
so now the dem's like well we got to be
wild if we want [ __ ] to resonate or else
nobody's going to notice
imagine a porn company there's one porn
company out here is doing [ __ ] anal
coming on faces and other stuff and then
the other porn company is softcore
nobody's watching the software anymore
they're like well we got to step it up
if we want to get some attention we
don't even want to play that game
so dems [ __ ] don't [ __ ] with trump
republicans
don't like trump yes he speaks to
some of their values but the
establishment republicans are held
hostage
by trump and his voters because those
republicans
voters their voters [ __ ] with trump
so now if you're an average republican
you got to kind of kiss trump's ass so
you don't piss off
your voters because they [ __ ] with
trumpism right
so the opportunity for dems and
republicans
to eliminate trump from the social
discourse
allows politics to get back to what
they've always done which is pretty much
nothing
but continue operating that way yeah so
i think what they're doing is if you
impeach
you can never run for president again
that's the main reason why they do that
and yeah there's a bunch of other
benefits you get when you're
post-present you get like a stipend a
year you get like 200 grand
like just like you guess what is a
secret service
secret service for all for like into
perpetuity like all these other benefits
there's a little financial
more than the financial i think what
they're doing is trying to take away
influence yeah
right because if he's off twitter he's
off instagram he's off all these social
platforms
and he can no longer run again he can't
threaten to run and parlor got shut down
apparently yeah oh taking off the app
store okay
yeah yeah and it's like so we could have
that conversation about is this an
attack on conservative values or
whatever but like i think the first
thing is just like what is the
immediate reaction to trump right and i
think that
if you're an establishment politician on
either side
you want that thorn in your side out of
here
because he can really shake [ __ ] up and
if you completely silence him or censor
him whatever it is
now he can't shake [ __ ] up in the same
way and they're gonna use
this storm in the capital thing as a way
to absolutely bury him as they should it
was
asinine it was [ __ ] he's a buffoon
for even telling [ __ ] to do
this [ __ ]
but the fact that he even gave them this
opportunity to shut his ass up and
remove
any leverage he would have had for the
next four years to get his son
in office or to get anybody else in
office i mean like super
dumb move at the end of his presence
nobody has bumbled the end of a
presidency or the end of like any
position of power
this badly i think in american history
no i yeah i don't i can't think of
anybody else i don't know i mean maybe
i'm trying to think like can you think
of anybody that towards the end of their
presidency they were
this much of a [ __ ] up like they he he's
gonna get impeached
in the last [ __ ] week he's in the
office i think they can even do it
after they could but he because of
actions within the last 11 days of his
term
yeah that's what he might get impeached
for and it's like that's to your point
you bungled this you know what this is
so badly you're in prison
you've got a week left on your sentence
and you're fine you kill a [ __ ]
or you fight somebody and then they're
like all right you're here for two more
years yeah
you [ __ ] idiot yeah you could have
left office had
the republican party balls in your hand
and whenever you wanted to apply some
pressure to get whatever the [ __ ] you
wanted just squeeze a little bit
that's what trump could have done that
guy had 75 million people who [ __ ] [ __ ]
with him
right and let's say he kept 50 million
that's massive
nada and if he gets some peach he can't
pardon himself
oh [ __ ] that's another big one he can't
part of himself or any of his other
cronies that he wants to
um interesting oh now it makes a lot of
sense yeah
okay so this is like removing any
political leverage or capital that trump
might
might have post-presidency and any like
legal ramifications that he can go to to
like free himself in any way
whoa yeah he [ __ ] up he [ __ ] up baby
[ __ ] up
or they positioned it to [ __ ] up
they took advantage of the opportunity
yeah but he gave him the opportunity
he never called him off until it was too
late yeah and there's actually an
article i
sent a link to that i read and didn't
fully understand but some european
allies believe trump attempted a coup of
the us government
with help from like feds like federal
officers
which is essentially like how did you
even let them get to the capitol steps
what one i think uh french person was
saying that was like i
am in a similar position to the whoever
the capital police is or whatever
the fact that they even got to the steps
of the capitol shouldn't have happened
once they got on the steps and started
to get in
you couldn't stop it they never should
have gotten that close so maybe there
had to be some kind of come uh
complicit like understanding this is
tacit understanding is the term
they were trying to like give him
yourself no just
he that some european allies think they
were all trying to trump was trying to
stage a coup and he had their
uh like like whatever their their
support
yeah which is scary truly stage a coup
i mean you need some sort of like
weaponry to do that
right you can't just go into the capitol
building and then like hang out with all
the congressmen and
and just hope that they go okay i guess
the country's yours now no but if the
vote never happens
then biden is never officially president
that's true they really were trying to
actually stop the vote so if they stop
the vote
then there's more of a chance that trump
could potentially play out his
presidency
and even if they delayed it there's
probably some like legal way where trump
could go technically i'm still president
we haven't verified that
biden is the incumbent and you do need
to punish that in the harshest possible
way to send a message that we're not
doing this again
like that is in any way shape or form
the people that went in there were
trying to overthrow the government
temporarily or whatever
you're bringing in a confederate flag
put aside slavery which is obviously a
very big deal but
the confederacy aside though because
yeah thank you
yeah yeah it's about time just won't let
that happen bro yeah
they won't let it happen keep going come
on
how many water fountains yeah do you
have to make yeah hundreds of years a
lot of people are sleeping
what's going on what i think we stayed
up north guys
what a [ __ ] hypocrite oh my god damn
man i get it seinfeld you're not that
bad
[ __ ] not that bad what if we go down
south and just start comedians and cars
drink
[ __ ] kubonitos or whatever these are
cars eating cubans
that's it let's go baby but wait you
were saying but those are traders like
the confederates were traders they went
against their
government tried to secede and all that
and then you're carrying that flag in
you are traders that's just what it is
you have to punish that harshly can't
have this happen so the punishment for
treason is death
they brought gallows i'm okay with that
like finally duties
remember when the lady got shot in her
forehead she got duty she got dutied
right
i or as we call it oops she got oops and
she got duty
she got troops in duties it's your turn
call of duty i don't know where we're on
patreon for that no but we put that up
oh we didn't put that out
okay so she got duty now you guys were
trying to make me feel bad
for saying she got dutied then i did a
little bit more reading turns out
these [ __ ] dragged a policeman
out of the building or like he was on
the steps beat the [ __ ] out of that
[ __ ] i think he died
he did die die to those injuries by the
way he was a trump supporter
[ __ ] dumbasses that did that yeah
nobody talking about that now
um so he's getting his ass beat like yo
i'm i let y'all in for a reason
i'm with it go her office is last on the
left and then
if i'm hearing my boy go yo they're
beating the [ __ ] out of me
they just dragged me down the stairs
that's my call of duty that's it anybody
who comes in a room
is headshots for everybody i have no
problem with this
why are we saying that's crazy that's
what i always say but [ __ ] work
tear me up email about it for saying
they all should have got shot you know
what offended me the most not all of
them
anybody who broke in after you point the
gun and you say you can't come in and
you just heard that that's why
we got killed by them same people i
think anybody trying to break in yes
it's a government it's like it's our
capital were people mad because
they thought it was interesting equality
because there's gender equality
he didn't think for a second he was just
like all right you're there
gender neutral is click click
all people matter because they thought
it was like bad taste to be rejoicing
that someone died yes
it's not rejoice i'm not happy but it is
what it is
no you you're not i'm not happy enough
almost happy nobody's happy
that anyone died i'm just saying they
deserved can i say
the punishment was worth the crime you
mean it's not about worth
because that it seems like it's
justified it's just what happens yeah
do you know what i'm saying like i think
about anybody whether you're black white
male or female anybody who is doing that
deserve
i would have a harder time shooting a
woman because i'd probably just go like
that with one finger and push her back
in that's what i would do personally
okay i would take a single finger and
just push her in her forehead and she
would just
would you just fall back in the door i
wouldn't shoot her you know i think
that's the first thing you do
all right but if that [ __ ] that
looked like mark with the tattoos and
the vikings and all that kind of [ __ ]
yeah if he was coming through that
window
valhalla is that ball holla that's the
bike
in heaven it's the viking heaven you
going to valhalla yeah that's all i'm
saying bro